but there are definitely some insecure
men who see like hot chicks on the
internet and they're like oh you're a
[ __ ] you're a [ __ ] and blah blah blah
and it happens to me yeah but they're
salty
why do you think they're salty i think
they're salty because they don't get
attention from a woman like you i agree
i i definitely agree with that and it's
the same reason that that a
non-attractive girl needs badly for you
to be called a [ __ ] yeah
whether you are you're not i'll tell you
why these guys are mad it's like they're
told not to sexualize women while women
are objectifying themselves on the
internet and then
women are telling them no and guys are
like well why can't i get with this girl
so they're in women are so entitled and
they put these guys down in rejection so
that's the reason why and so they're
they end up never mind i won't go that
way go there what do you mean no no
what don't you want to say
sorry we're here because we want to get
some answers women have a higher
standard of physical beauty than like
men
men are told
not to objectify women women
continuously objectify themselves they
say don't touch me don't talk to me
don't do this there's like new laws that
say if you even approach a woman you can
be arrested for harassment in other
countries did you know that no no what
country is in the uk for example uk it's
basically so what are the reasons for
these laws is it is it an overstretch is
it overreach what do you think is
happening right here
why are they doing it probably because
women got together and said i don't want
this in the moment
they weren't i don't know sometimes i
think well i won't say that either well
let me ask you ladies here yeah do you
like like you guys are attractive women
if i don't you get that hold on
girl guys must come up to you
consistently
and some are creepier some are not
creepier some are assumed gentlemen some
are complete [ __ ] but they talk to
you
isn't that do you view that as a
compliment is it annoying
how do you perceive that i think it's
definitely both it can be like it's a
compliment of course because if men are
approaching you then i mean i guess that
means you're probably not attractive
unless you're going to go like approach
a man why would you want to do that so
of course they're going to come talk to
you but like
i don't see that as a huge problem i
really don't when men come to talk to
you yeah they think i don't think so
unless it's like it starts to be like
it's like oh you're trying to be like on
some creepy [ __ ] it's all crazy it's all
based on sex like they want to have sex
with you even the ones that are nice to
you yeah so
it just means they have good game right
[Music]